on the ground in Iowa tonight first
during my exclusive super down super
bowl sit-down interview with the
president I did ask him about the
media's disdain for his supporters and
working-class Americans I specifically
brought up what we all witnessed in
shock with CNN fake news Don Lemon his
recent efforts to degrade Trump voters
here's what the President had to say
he saw Don Lemon this past week and the
Laughing basically at Trump supporters
that smelly Trump Walmart shoppers
irredeemable deplorable z-- Americans is
a comment Obama made bitter Americans
that cling to their their God their
Bibles and religion seems like there's a
contempt for people that don't share
their worldview so I watch this guy he's
terrible you know now unlearn it
he's not a smart person at all but I
watched that phony laugh that wasn't a
laugh he was he was trying to act puts
his head down oh he's laughing so hard
there was nothing funny about what was
said here with reaction former Arkansas
governor presidential candidate himself
Mike Huckabee our own Katie Pavlich is
with us you know governor irredeemable
deplorable --zz let's see smelly Walmart
shoppers guilty clinging to God guilty
our Constitution I'm guilty
Bibles guilty and religion guilty and I
love Walmart guilty is charged what does
this tell us about what people in the
establishment elite class in DC New York
LA San Francisco think of We the People
Sean they live in their bubbles and they
really don't get out much and they don't
understand the rest of the country but
all they're doing is just driving more
support to President Trump for his
reelection I mean they just insulted
over 80 million Americans with that kind
of stuff in Don Lemon giggling like an
eight-year-old girl at his birthday
party I've never seen anything quite as
ridiculous CNN should have called him in
and said you can't be a news anchor and
fall down on your desk and giggle like
that is just unprofessional but you know
let them do what they want to do because
I'm telling you
and back to bite him not people aren't
watching Katie we look at ratings
everyday well I saw CNN being played at
the Bernie rally there Sean and was
thinking that oh they're actually
getting millions of viewers tonight
because they were playing in the
background on your show but I think one
of the most impressive and important
messages the president has gotten out
there is that it's not that they just
hate him
they hate the American people who voted
for him and he's just in the way and
they repeatedly state that on the
campaign trail and it certainly is
resonating with Democrats is 25% of them
are attending his rallies imagine if
they have to say the words in 274 days
we can now project Donald J Trump has
been reelected the 45th president